We are waiting for somebody from your side. Let me know when you are completed.
Hi, Rick.
All right.
Yeah, I think it's the I think it's just the three of us today.
Hi, Alan.
Ah.
Yeah, I'm just waiting for Ashish. Let me see if he can try, yeah.
Oh, is that Chaudhary?
Okay. Well, I didn't need to be on for long. I just wanted to pop on and say hi to Orlando because we've only checked in once or twice.
OK, got it.
Why I said I don't always get to join these calls, so I saw it pop up and wanted to say hello. That's all.
Okay, perfect.
Everything going okay for you, Orlando, with Santiago?
Oh yeah, absolutely. He's doing very good. He's practically taking ownership of all the Nutanix stuff. I'm very happy for that because he's practically doing what I want.
Mhm.
At.
The only the only plan that we have right now, I going to spoke with him today, is related to the time stamps, the time time set up.
Time entry.
Yeah, the time attendance, there is something that practically is not supposed to be an issue because, you know, there's some stuff related to the way that he make the time registers.
But related to the to the stuff that I'm really worried about, it is doing good for now, so...
Good. Very, very happy to hear. Thank you. And I know you've got a good team here working with you on it. So, hey, Ashish.
Hi, Lee, hi, Orlando, how are you?
Priya.
Hi, I think everything's good.
Amit.
Great. All right, well, I'm going to drop off. Like I said, I just had a couple of minutes and I wanted to pop on and say hello. Kip, Ash, Rick, thank you so much for running the call. And Orlando, good to hear from you. I appreciate you sharing the feedback early. I know it's going to be the first thing that Kip or Ashish asked anyway, but
Yeah.
Gaur.
But I appreciate it and glad to hear. And yeah, we'll keep chugging along in the right direction.
Okay, perfect.
I'll talk with you all soon.
Banguilan.
Cheers.
So, Orlando, anything apart from the time entries which you think we need to...
Okay.
Log on.
No, apart of that, just this little topic. Like I said, I'm going to talk to him about it. There's no big deal with that. So it's just like sometimes the person that managed the
Yeah.
Time clock tool. She always have this kind of.
Mm.
Of requirements about the the the timestamp needs to be they are in the.
in particular time. Actually, we are discussing that internally because probably we will need to be a little bit flexible with that because his role, he done depends to be in a phone call queue or something similar. So I understand that we can
OK.
be from our side, of course, a little bit flexible with that. So I'm going to discuss that internally.
Okay.
So, that, that's not for, for be clear, that's not a real issue right now. So, that's just, I'm just tell you for, you know, for let you know that that's the only thing, but it's not something related to the performance of Shishan.
Yes.
Okay, understood. Thank you for sharing.
Kip.
Yeah.
And Orlando, do we also have connects with Shashank? Like maybe weekly, like check-ins, like how he's doing and anything that you would identify proactively, let us know and we can work with Shashank on the same.
Okay, yeah. For now, I understand that he's doing good, you know. I practically assigned to him plays up today all the all the mechanics and we were clusters that we are managing. Some of them he's consulting with me because some of them I need
to spoke with the customer and request any possible maintenance window or sometimes it's just because the client is a little bit...
Mmh.
I don't know how to call, but they always want, hey, don't do anything without let me know or consulting with me. Even do not represent any kind of downtime from the system. So
That's the only ones that we are, we're still pending, but for the rest of them, he's doing good. And actually, he's...
Okay.
Even he's working with the...
with the upgrade process and all the stuff, he's working to in the solving alerts that he'd find by himself in the clusters. He just asked me, hey, can I work with that? Yeah, sure, you can do it. He opened a couple of support cases with Nutanix too that was
Is good, because, and normally does depend from from us.
But, you know, in this way, I'm very happy with them. Actually, the team, the whole team is very happy with them.
Yes.
Thank you, Orlando. Thank you so much.
Right.
Another thing, Orlando, you would think that I'm keeping asking the questions to you, but we would like to understand how we measure Shashank's success with you guys. I think during the onboarding call with Rick,
He must have given you a glimpse of the KPIs that we would use to measure Shashank against those numbers. So anything that you have decided for engineers like Shashank who is...
S.
Yeah.
an offshore engineer for you, so there would be certain parameters that are not applicable to him, but obviously there are certain which are, and as per your experience, the best suited KPIs for Shashank, we would like to get those from you and...
Start measuring Sushant on sale.
Okay, yeah, in this case, normally the way that I normally will wait is like, of course, the task that I assign and...
I'm constantly reviewing the the the job that the that all the technicians doing.
You know, I have practically in charge of two different chips, second and third. He's working particularly in the third, but normally he handles some pending cases from the second chip. So I'm constantly investing in the operation, even if he don't know me for some.
Kip.
For one day, because this day I decide that I need to sleep some some kind of hours, a couple of hours, but...
Yeah, if you guys from our side, we don't have a formal a formal way to measure like a like a some kind of or forms or something similar to that. I think that.
Somebody of you sent to us one example of the form that you guys use. I can check that if you want to, I can fill it and send you back for, you know, for the purposes that you have this documentation for your site.
Mhm.
You just let...
Yeah, sure. I think I think that is this is doable. So Kip can obviously share the recommended KPIs that most of our partners follow. But again, there could be some KPIs which are not a best example of what Sushant does.
Kip.
So you are free to edit those KPIs, even if you feel the weightage of some of the parameters are not reflecting the true nature of this work. You can also do the addition there. And when we meet next week, we would discuss on those finalized KPIs and set the percentage of
For various parameters, and we'll we'll move it from there.
I think Ashish, Orlando, if you remember, we did review this one. Ashish, just FYI, that this was discussed with Orlando and Luis.
Okay.
And is it same which Kip Kip will be sharing, Ashish?
Yeah.
Uh, no, these are not the same.
No, not again.
Okay, perfect, then I'm good.
Yeah, I'm just looking for the for the one, the only the only one that I had right now here is the career development. I'm checking that there's a lot of emails here.
Just trying to check.
Scorecard and the 30, 60, 90 plan, three things would be there.
Yeah.
But if you can, you can send me back the form.
Yep, I can share.
I really appreciate that. For the next, oh yeah, I think that I found here, the scoreboard, right?
Yep.
Yeah, I see it here. I see her. Yeah. I see it.
Okay.
Uh, Excel.
Okay, got it. So I got it here.
So I can easily can fill that in the next week. We can.
I can send to you.
Lit up.
Yep, that.
And discussing the case that you, so...
Okay.
Sure, well, yeah, sure.
Support.
Okay, Kip, can you quickly share the utilization numbers of Sushant from the past week?
Yeah, sure. So, Orlando, I'm going to share my screen and we can quickly review Shashank's last week numbers, like how he performed or what kind of work he did. So let me share my screen. And from next call onwards, we will be
Yeah.
Yep.
Using this presentation to review his performance.
Ohh.
Okay.
So this is for the last week starting June 27th till July 1st. And this would be the agenda, check in highlights, action tracker, way forward and recap.
Hoh.
Check in we already did. We discussed about how things are moving and these are some key updates on the account so far. Like we have been getting good feedback on Santiago. He is participating in upgrade planning, execution, remediation activities, matching activities.
He completed his onboarding and knowledge transfer, also getting familiar with the tools. He is currently involved with DRPC upgrades, Nutanix upgrades, VMware upgrades, and batch management activities.
So this is the action tracker which we were discussing earlier, the 30, 60 and 90 day plan, which you already mentioned that you will be sharing with us soon.
And these are the KPIs that we were discussing.
Great.
So this is, these are the KPIs in which we recommend. That includes the billable utilization, 80%, but again, it varies, so it depends like the way Shank works in off hours. So if you think 80% is achievable.
Mhm.
Hoh.
you can get enough work, then that's fine. If you want to change it, you can feel free to change it to whatever the numbers you think are feasible or achievable.
Okay, got it.
But in this case, I understand that this number for the available utilization is perfect. Actually, normally, for the kind of work that it's doing, it can be hard, but using 80% of target, I understand that it's more than...
Yeah.
more than comprehensible. So we can go with this number.
Okay, and ticket resolved rate 8 to 10 per day, but again, because he is also involved or mostly involved in the project work. So 8 tickets per day because project tickets are mostly the long running tickets. So yeah, what do you think 8 to 10 is good or you want to?
Exactly.
Change it to something else.
No, I no, no. In this case, I cannot give you a specific a specific number because, for example, all the tickets that he that he's handled right now is tickets related to upgrades, and normally one one ticket can take him all the shifts.
So.
So, you know, it's a little bit hard to determine a specific number for this.
Yeah.
For this kind of...
A flat hour, you know.
So Orlando, Orlando, what we can do is, since these are the recommended KPIs, which most of our partners follow, we will tweak these KPIs to best suit what is being done by Shashank, and we will share those numbers with those KPIs with you.
Mohit.
And then you let us know if you are comfortable with those KPIs or you want us to make any changes to it. So let's not discuss the recommended KPIs because these are applicable to engineers who work with tickets often, not for engineers like Shashank who works on projects.
Yeah.
Yeah, I...
Yeah, I I think that maybe that will be better to determine the quantity of hours documented.
Yeah.
Because that will be a real, that will be a more real, a more real data related to the to the task that they are doing, because, to be honest, it's going to be a little bit not
Yeah, so I will.
Right.
Injustice for him for determining quantity of, yeah, quantity of tickets per day, it's not it's not far, you know.
We understand.
Haight.
S.
Ashish.
Mhm.
Yeah, completely understandable. I will share these KPIs with you over the e-mail. You can review internally and let us know what amends you want to make.
We got it.
Okay, got it. Yeah, sure.
Kour.
So let's quickly jump into the performance. So this is his utilization for the last term from 27th till 1st. He's already at 80%. So which is good. So.
Yeah, he's pretty close to the target already.
And the dip in the end on 1st July, that was maybe probably due to the long, long weekend coming. So.
Yes.
Apart from the rest of the days, he was pretty close to the target.
Yeah, sure.
And this is his ticket data. So as I was, we were discussing earlier, so per day he has maximum work done 5 tickets on 30th of June. So based on the ticket data, we can decide like how many tickets he can handle, which should be good.
for measuring his performance. But the ticket closure is pretty strong with almost 100% closure on the tickets, so which is again a good thing.
Kit.
Okay.
So these are the projects he has been involved in, that is the Nutanix infrastructure upgrades, VMware upgrade, patch management, alert and incident remediation, compatibility assessment, and also following up with the vendors where he has some dependency. So.
Yeah, practically that's exactly what he's doing right now.
Right, right.
Right, so way forward, we will keep on.
doing the board reviews with him, keep a check on him regarding any gaps, if there are any in terms of process or technical gaps, and also to increase the consistency and throughput and tickets resolution. And also
We are waiting on the 36 to 20 day plan. So once you complete that, please share that with us.
Yeah, sure.
And this is the build it, which is coming on August 5th, August 3rd till five. I hope you're already aware. And in case you need any further information, do let us know. We will share that with you.
Okay, got it.
So, and this is our team GPS in house too, so I hope you're already aware, and that's it.
I will share this presentation with you along with the KPIs and you can review internally and do let us know if you want to make any changes.
Okay, perfect. Sounds good.
Uh, anything else, uh, Ashish?
No, I'm good. It was a pleasure meeting you, Orlando. We'll catch up next week and we'll talk more about KPIs for the Shark.
I just want to ask something about the day that we are that we are making the meeting. I'm I'm thinking about if it's possible to change the day for Wednesdays, because practically the Wednesdays is the first day off.
Yep.
Yeah.
Mm.
of Chauhan, so I can practically review all the complete week for him. I don't know if you guys have his availability. If you had it, we can move to change to Wednesday. Of course, for me right now, it's going to be a little bit better because I can let you know how was the complete week.
Okay.
That he worked, I don't know what you think about it.
Yep, no, that's fine. So what time would work for you? Any slots, available slots for Wednesdays?
It makes sense.
Same time, same time, Wednesdays.
Let me quick.
Is it?
It can be, it can be later, it can be, well, yeah, it can be later. In my case, it just needs to be later.
Or let me share, yeah, later. I don't have any any other time slots.
So, later.
Because normally I start my shift normally at 1 P.m. Puerto Rico time.
On the two, I have the shift handoff between the 1st and 2nd shift, so normally this time slot I'm busy.
So, so Orlando, your time is same as Eastern Standard Time, right? Atlantic is same as Eastern.
Exactly, exactly. But keep it in mind that Atlantic time in November changed, but in Puerto Rico, but in Puerto Rico, that does not change.
Yeah, you don't follow the latest events. Yep, I am aware of this.
And.
Okay.
Okay, understood.
You know, it took us some time to understand the difference between our timings, the days, how it will reflect in Eastern, then in Indian Standard Time. So I was, we were able to find a common standard time that is Eastern Day Time that you guys are following. So we are comfortable with that.
The.
So, thank you so much.
Yeah, yeah, actually, for you right now, it's Tuesday, right?
It is, it is stupid, yeah.
Yes.
Hey, you're talking to me from the future.
Yeah, you know, that makes me recall an instance that happened with one of my partners when I used to be an engineer. So they were from Idaho. And I wish them a new year from the future.
Okay.
Yeah, actually, for us, for us, is very is very interesting because part of our team is from Argentina. Some of them are from Mexico, other ones are from Spain. Right now, Shashan is from India. Personally, I am located in
Texas in the United States. So there's in Christmas, there's two hours of difference with Puerto Rico. So normally in the, when they pass the New Year's year, I'm still in the previous year. I always send them a message like a,
Ashish.
Mhm.
Happy New Year from the from the last year.
The.
Yeah, yeah.
Hoh.
Crazy World.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well, guys, uh...
All right, well, it was nice talking to you, Orlando. So Kip will share the updated device as promised, and we will meet as per the schedule. So it is Wednesday, so this week is already gone, so I believe upcoming call is...
to happen on 15th of July, that's Wednesday.
Yep.
Yeah.
Alright.
And time should be same. 3pm. Okay, cool.
3 PM Eastern. 33.
The same time. 3pm. 3pm.
Okay, cool. I will update the invite. Sure.
Yep.
Well, thank you. I really appreciate your time. You're welcome. Have a good one.
Thank you, Orlando.
Thank you so much.
Yep. Have a wonderful rest of the week. Bye.
Feeling is mature. Bye.